hello good afternoon I am Raja Lakshmi
I'm doing my electrical and electronics
in Piazza here moderate India I would
like to put forward my question to John
matter and the major thing is the
experiment which was conducted the Large
Hadron Collider experiment in France
recently and its results are also
astonishing my question is whether it
would answer some of town answered
questions in astrophysics that is will
it bring back the question regarding Big
Bang field and this is six thank you hi
Roger the biggest questions that
astronomers have that would be touched
on by the results from the Large Hadron
Collider in France those relate to the
fundamental particles that the universe
is built of and we have tremendous
mysteries about these when astronomers
want to understand what was the big bang
like we have to extrapolate from our
experiments way back to conditions that
were far more extreme than anything we
can possibly imagine so when we take
what we think are the properties of
protons and electrons and the things
that they're made out of quarks and
gluons we have to guess what they would
be like at the tremendous pressures and
temperatures that occurred in the early
universe so the closer we can get to
actually measuring those the better off
we are so that's the biggest question
that astronomers hope to get at through
understanding the Large Hadron Collider
data what were the particles like in the
Big Bang